and celebrating the massive stimulus in
the rose garden today
that no republicans supported and of
course he didn't take any questions from
reporters
as for last night if you thought the guy
who preached unity would share credit
for the vaccine think again
a year ago were hit with a virus
that was met with silence and spread
unchecked
denials for days weeks then months
we do this together by july the fourth
there's a good chance you
your families and friends will be able
to get together in your backyard or in
your neighborhood
and have a cookout at a barbecue and
celebrate independence day
if we don't stay vigilant and the
conditions change
then we may have to reinstate
restrictions to get back on track
and according to the liberal media it
was the best speech
ever he is the guy we need right now
i think it was very moving um
the president is very good at
articulating
empathy july 4th you know he put that on
the calendar as well so
right people are going to be looking at
their calendars now with some hope he
was sleepy joe
he's mojo joe now
that's fake praise i don't even believe
that greg come on
um what did you think of this speaker i
thought it was an adequate speech i was
not blown away
though no you know it wasn't awful but
it wasn't good
i think i do i find it hilarious that um
he is telling you how to celebrate on
independence day
so he's he's applying government
controls
on the day that commemorates our victory
over
government control and so what he ended
up doing is he's causing people
he's causing people to actually have
mass celebrations as a form
of american protest because that's what
americans do is they protest
but the media has two reflexes a they
either want to ruin you
or kiss your butt there's almost no
in-between anymore so the people who
wanted a coup
against trump when he won in 2016
that hysterical freaks on morning joe
and cnn now they're the same people
having joe gasms
and acting as though he's the best thing
since you know waffles covered in gravy
but the fact is the bar is so low for
joe
that basically what you're hearing is a
sigh of relief
that he made it after 50 days prepping
for 20 minutes
he made it yeah he barely made it juan
um i i thought it was kind of
workmanlike
he really struggles to communicate but
i just i don't know if he connected with
people he didn't connect with me
did he connect to juan williams
yeah big time you know when i hear jesse
and
greg say you know it was okay it wasn't
good it was average it was all right
i think that's pretty high praise for a
democrat
right so i think i think joe biden did
pretty well last night guys
i think you know to my mind look st
patrick's day has come
early i think there are a lot of critics
out there who are right now
green with envy at the job that uh joe
biden is doing
i mean you know he didn't boast last
night he had every right
to take a victory up i didn't hear that
what i heard him say was
we as an american people have to come
together right now
and if we come together we can get this
done we can take on this task
i mean you know this is what happens
when you have an adult in the room
you have someone who can speak to us as
an american people who can grieve for
those who have died
i think donald trump just wasn't up to
that or he choked but he didn't
get the job done and that's why he lost
the election
right now
his success is based on the vaccines
juan who got you the vaccines
who yeah biden got the vaccine before he
won the election
so where did those come from well
that's not the to my mind it's how much
we didn't have much vaccine when he came
in to vaccinate people like
you're doing the same race
way forward and i don't think we had a
way forward before
so hats off to joe biden
all right all right katie um
july 4th um does just joe realize that
we've been kind of going out to
restaurants and
seeing our family for the last i don't
know year at least
yeah good news america king biden will
allow you to barbecue now
in your own backyard with your family so
long
as you are vaccinated i have news for
you the people in florida have been
grilling gator
in their backyard at gatherings for
months on end now and everything has
been just fine
and the cdc has been saying for a year
that people can gather with masks on
you have people stuffing themselves into
airplanes and flying across the country
and i'm pretty sure last summer people
gathering outdoors six feet apart
that was following the science so people
could celebrate independence day so when
he says we need to
throw off the shackles of the virus to
celebrate july 4th
i don't think he that that went the way
that he thought it was going to go in
terms of the messaging on that but
um people have been barbecuing i would
have chosen memorial day maybe
that might have been a closer and uh
they're already doing it
historically significant holidays i've
already been doing it
this is not a new thing people have been
doing this outdoor we were told you can
be outside with your friends
for a year now this is not a new idea
that's right all right shannon your
thoughts
well listen if you want people to feel
excited about going out and getting the
vaccine i don't think you tell them
we've got millions tens of millions of
people vaccinated everybody's going to
get a vaccine by may 1st who wants one
every adult
but it's still going to be two more
months before we decide if you can go in
your backyard if you're going to drive
people to the vaccines i think that was
the wrong message to send
and also i don't recall any mention from
him last night of the border where we
know in at least one area the covet
positive testing of people coming across
the border is over nine percent if that
was the case in a major city like new
york or san francisco whatever they
would be on lockdown again
so i don't think he can say to the
american people listen focus we got to
get through this thing and at the same
time ignore what's happening at the
border
and people coming across who are then
there's no power to stop them from
traveling further into the u.s
if you're serious about the virus and
you're going to make the rest of us
behave and follow the rules and
warn us that you're going to get more
rules if you don't behave i think you
have to take the border situation
seriously and if americans
don't think that you are they're going
to be hesitant to comply with all the
other rules
yeah there was no way speech writers
were adding the border
to that speech last night but we'll see
what happens on that front